pomme Clemente F had to undergo a major
transformation in order to portray the
empath mantis in the MCU and it wasn't
just a physical one her character has
such a unique background and power set
that Clemente F had to go through some
serious mental effort to become the
adorable alien we know and love actors
who portray superheroes tend to have
some pretty strict dietary rules in
order to achieve the impressive physique
they need that is even more apparent
when you factor in the ridiculous body
standards that celebrity women must deal
with but Clemente F's diet is not as
strict as you might think
she just changes it to suit her needs
for whatever role she is currently
playing in an interview with birdy
Clemente F discussed her upbringing and
how her diet changes dependent on the
current role she's playing she explained
I grew up eating amazing homemade French
food now if I tell myself I can't eat
something I'm just going to be obsessed
with it like bread I love bread for me
it's about quantity balance I eat a
little bit of everything I'm vegan in LA
but not in Europe
Tom Clemente IFS first major Hollywood
role was in Spike Lee's remake of Oldboy
she told filler that she actually came
prepared to show off her fighting skills
during the audition for that film and
that she enjoyed her boxing and
Taekwondo training so much that she
continued after filming wrapped it's
easy to assume that may have had
something to do with her getting cast in
the action-heavy world of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe superhero Jax writes
that Clemente F does almost no
traditional workouts it's all practical
stunts and fight training this also
helps prepare her for the rigors of long
shooting days she told filler I had to
train three hours a day for two months
you are sore every day and you're
working on your soreness mantis isn't
the heaviest hitter in the guardians of
the galaxy or Avengers films but maybe
Clemente Epps training and fighting and
stunts will open her character up to
some more action heavy roles in future
MCU films several stars of the guardians
of the galaxy films need to spend hours
in the makeup chair to achieve their
alien looks Karen Gillan knows it's not
easy being blue Dave Bautista Drax is
encased in
medics and intricate tattoos and don't
even get us started on how much fur they
have to glue on Bradley Cooper Clemente
of Samantha's is no exception but she
actually does not require quite as much
time in the makeup chair as some of her
co-stars Clemente F typically spends
about two and a half to three hours in
makeup to play mantis that might sound
crazy but it's only about half the time
that Zoe Saldana has to spend getting
painted green to play Gamora that's
because of the combination of practical
makeup effects and CGI that brings
mantis to life her look is created with
a few basic prosthetics and according to
Metro quote a lot of beauty makeup
apparently one of the most difficult
makeup challenges Clemente F faces is
keeping a straight face she said of
co-star Chris Pratt it's hard to keep a
straight face around him I laughed so
hard I was crying and my makeup artist
was kind of mad at me part of the
struggle in making an audience care
about alien characters is to make them
just human enough to be relatable
I am mantis what are you doing smiley
Clemente F has recognized the difficulty
and experimentation that went into
making sure mantis was slightly
off-putting but still someone you could
empathize with and cheer for she told
Metro we tried a lot of stuff we tried
different wigs at some point the makeup
artist drew veins on my face contact
lenses at some point I looked really
crazy and then we decided to go for
something a little more human black eyes
that make me look like a bug but at the
same time something you can still
connect to it was extremely important to
get mantises eyes just right people are
able to learn a great deal about
another's emotions and mental state by
looking in their eyes despite going way
out into left field for their initial
shots at mantises makeup the team
eventually anchored her humanity through
her eyes mantis has a very fascinating
superpower one that could be difficult
to portray on screen her ability to feel
and manipulate the emotions of others is
pretty passive compared to her butt
kicking companions but sadly Clemente F
is able to draw on several experiences
from
real life in order to bring genuine pain
and emotion to her character her father
died when she was only 5 years old while
her mother was mentally ill and unable
to care for her alone
she went on to live with her aunt and
uncle not long after her father's death
the uncle who was caring for her died on
her 18th birthday and her brother took
his own life on her 25th birthday she
told The Philadelphia Inquirer that
acting has helped her deal with the pain
its life and could be worse it's
cathartic in a way sometimes you relive
things and it helps you to deal with it
you relive it and become accepting of it
and you touch other people's hearts with
your experience and performance it's
beautiful she was able to channel some
of the loneliness and abandonment she
felt as a child and how her long
isolated and empathetic character would
view the world around her check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]